in the prize e psp wii o maria che dolor
the chiaro mi amorfa chiedere quello è
esageratamente j ax non lo vedi che
canta maria che dolore in gigante one
the one bus pack botti li ammazzo
familia è rimasta bottiglia salvo tua
figlia ma verrà tutti ragazzi pervenuti
a questo nuovo video e sono felice oggi
siamo tra di suez
vorrei chiudere questo video col
telecomando adesso però ci aspettano in
dieci minuti dei più belli buoni come
siete contenti e anch'io lo sono perché
questo gioco mi manda gli steria più
totale porcaccia troy il 99,9 per cento
imposti volete questo 99 è anche troppo
male sempre gli otto meglio di me alla
fine di capodanno però ridotto molto
peggio di così io sto giocare ad happy
meals ci gioco solo da quattro anni ma
sono proprio in grado sono
incredibilmente in grado di giocare a
questo gioco dopo quattro anni che ci
gioco porta di una eva lercia il mio
cuore ha vinto e di questi tempi il
cuore che vince vale tanto perché non
c'è più amore nell'aria va bene va bene
va bene un cazzo ben dai dai l'ho
toccato stronzo è scemo
adesso non l'ho toccato ma me l'ha dato
baby rock swing 7 ma cosa ma non potete
mandare un bambino a fare queste cose
morto mica sono morti tutti
ha quindi devo aggrapparmi fantastico
devo centrare la vittoria quanto
difficile fi mamma rai mamma sei tutti
noi mamma sei tutti noi
ho vinto con la madre cup ha commentato
non ho vinto perché non ci sono ancora
arrivato ma queste bellissime bottiglie
di buon vino chianti e accompagna
benissimo grazie sono riuscita vice con
la madre che non ci trova una sega prove
vuol dire dermica su happy with hanno
fatto would you reder stato esploso
qualcosa in lontananza ma non me ne
frega niente
ok vuol dire è farmi leggere non ho
letto cazzo però beccato quella con la
percentuale migliore quindi mi sa che ho
beccato con la migliore in assoluto
preferiresti prendere il lavoro dei tuoi
sogni ma farti pagare veramente poco o
sposarti
ma la donna che è esposi è pazza e non
puoi divorziare
sto pare già scritto che era pazza non
che non è [ __ ] preferiresti saldare in
una piscina piena di aghi o uccidere
tutti i tuoi parenti e non sarai
arrestato infatti tutti hanno scelto
uccidere tutti i parenti
che schifo non salta riva in una piscina
piena di animo non potresti essere mezzo
nero e mezzo bianco quindi michael
jackson oppure un mezzo uomo e mezzo
donna io sono sia mezzo uomo e mezzo da
ma già adesso che è lancio degli urletti
che giovanna d'arco può accompagnare
soldi la parte di sotto e maschile e la
parte di sopra e femminile quindi io
avrò le tette il pene guarda potessi
scegliere di diventarlo adesso
diventerei così leveresti salvare il
replay o votare quello che vuoi votare
quello che vuoi perché voterò una stella
ok sono comunque le percentuali le
avranno messe completamente a caso
perché non aveva senso prova plans
versus segue i gay mi sembra tanto
vecchio sono uno zombie prova bene
quello he ping shooter chiama così
io non ho mai giocato a pranzo proprio
zombies in tutta la mia vita però ok
bene ultra nair fede blauer nei fatti
simo zio va bene soprattutto il cannone
lava guava chi gioca di voglia blood
verdi sicuramente sta capendo quello che
sto facendo perché non lo so a te ne
stai calmo frate devi stare calmo spike
with sono uscite a morire dallo spice
with se voi sapete che cos'è tirategli
un calcio da parte mia ho fatta sono
fatta ciò fatta solo forte fortissimo
bene non ha capito una secca di suo
livello pubblici i nove zeri mente
quanto figo perché si è aperto blocco
note ai hope you like this level finish
before the end un errore tesori gravi
nella brasserie tra c'è scritto quello
che lo giuro devo entrare ma è tutto
contaminato qua perché dove entrare
perché devo fare queste cose da solo
sono entrati in un universo parallelo
oddio questo è successo è partita la mia
ombra colleziona tutte le monete e voi
attraverso la finestra per chi parla
introna che figata yen frey si è
liberata la mia ombra fatemi capire
quanto freestyler la mia ombra mica
bravissimo cazzo stimo la mia ombra veri
che centrava chernobyl in qualche modo
spiate
di quei livelli più figli che abbia mai
fatto ma non capisco il senso salve
quindi c'è padre di duke per cena oggi
fa piacere
ciao zio porca [ __ ] sono moltissimo ora
era un bel livello cazzo finito male
peccato però grafico harpoon run 2017 ci
mancavano al clan del 2017 sono guardati
di anno in anno questo gioco non fa che
migliorare e io non faccio che essere
sempre più contento se non riesco a fare
il tuo livello poi aver coop sei
autorizzato a mandarmi a fare in culo
solo se non ci riesco a te l'onore
affanculo
sì però devi stare calmo zio devi stare
calmo devi stare devi stare calmissimo
senti quelle cops ei tuoi fan ti fanno
sti livelli che porta di una [ __ ] non
riesce a farlo neanche il tipo che l'ha
fatto e non è colpa mia
ok ok tensione tensione questo è buono
qui ebbe il corpo può accompagnare solo
quanto fortunato 6 ma io ti dico
un'altra poco
si vabbè c'è una cosa verde c'era già
prima che riesca a prendere quella roba
lì devono morire tutti i folletti del
fanta mondo compreso joergen man
strangle che era quello più brutto
perfetto come faccio per farne uno solo
a metà di più una perla
chi è che ha fatto suo livello un genio
porca [ __ ] e il possibile
questo me lo sento mi sento mi sento
visto come ci sono andato molto vicino
dopo era lì è a caccia [ __ ] o quanto
difficile [ __ ]
ci sono tre valli botto il flip blu
magari una merda livello pre blu questo
valorizza il tutto
no no asp e forse continuerà così per il
resto della sua vita
la prendo al volo la prendo al volo
quella fermi non ci arriva prendere
l'ultima porca [ __ ] potranno mentre un
po più alta gioco di merda ma del jump
quota fucka
no no no no già che ti chiami il rodrigo
guevara zio va bene faccio il livello e
non ti puoi non chiamare rodrigo che
vara one day one bus pack bottini
ammazzo familia è rimasta bottiglia
salvo tua figlia
cech e chiappe sode zio perché vita se
non si è fatto nulla accadendo sulle
chiappe vuol dire che stai messo bene
frate fini devo non solo arrivata devo
prendere le due monete come se fosse
facile no porca eva perché tornati
indietro è scemo cazzola siamo fatta
calmi tutti gli schizzi che brutto
livello regala perché ho scelto di far
questo no speech a forma di stop e
neanche uno non riesco a prendermi basta
e impossibile basta subaru outback
il trojan
però magari in un casinò basta a venire
su bari in casinò famiglia oggi il babbo
vi porta al mare sedetevi comodi che io
so guidare come ai vecchi tempi tesoro
ed ora direte facciamo una roba mai
giona boi genna boy yugang powerhaul e
forse noi sud lightsaber sarai parte del
regno dei sith a star wars
sì ho scelto il male perché il bene era
banale fatto sono tumblr prendi un
superpotere random ma sarai odiato e la
gente si sia vent era di te
irrazionalmente e nessuno capirà mai
perché il cazzo te ne frega tanto cioè i
superpoteri in culo al mondo puoi avere
accesso a internet attraverso il tuo
cervello
minchia lo spot bellissimo vada in live
su youtube anche da la muraglia cinese
fantastico però sarei costantemente
spaventato da tutto questo
che cazzo se ne fregava bene su internet
sono scusa mi guardo sull'aereo su
internet ma stai scherzando ma [ __ ]
avrai la ragazza perfetta o il ragazzo
perfetto e lei sarà fantastica in tutte
le sue cose ma lei piace soltanto a te e
sarah orribile per tutti gli altri
aspetta che trovo il cazzo che me ne
frega in questa stanza guarda il cazzo
che me ne frega il grande quanto i miei
pantaloni in questo momento ovvero non
c'è les ma tutti avranno messo io spero
chiunque 41 per cento no non meritate la
[ __ ] mai nella vita fa anche rima avrà
il corpo perfetto ma dovrai indossare il
cappello sciocco tutti i giorni sì
perché tanto c'è il fisico da madonna
infatti tutti hanno messo sì grazie al
cazzo bene che livello istruttivo che
era wes borland
ap cos'è sta roba
madonna 6 calmo dai frate già posso fare
dai che ce la posso fare gioco stufare
by yoox e tutti noi porca [ __ ] quanto
amo mio figlio
però non mi ha dato la vittoria ma va
bene ciao so fare anch'io ce la posso
fare anch'io non ce la faccio devo
riuscirci o ragazzi se non mi va bene
ca di una [ __ ] mi sono stordito le
orecchie e tua madre
bruttissima locke jump gen bonucci ai
welcome to dei blocchi jump reitman
think you this va bene ho fatto zio 98
video matera per cento il prossimo
questo non è un imposti come mi hai
mentito alimenti tu menti dove riuscirà
a prendere il caso di lato per riuscire
a darmi la spinta giusta vero perfetto
ok ok non da quella parte dall'altra
pirla dall'altra dall'altra sei scemo
madonna va ce ne vuole per sé
[ __ ] come te zio porco è bravo
file e capriola in questo momento non
serve un pene ma ce la fai
praga sono ero bloccato non ho capito il
perché ero bloccato solo four giusto
livello impossibile ma attenzione
questo e il massimo di spinta che sei
riuscito a darti frate fai veramente
piangere avere cassiere che posso
concludere qui livello chromazone
ginepri usa un momento è un mi piace ai
capace di facebook e come il totale
l'ascrizione senza vestiti scateni cv
diavolo costituito da ragazzi